let's pull up this story here from The
New York Times Reporter arrested while
covering news conference in Ohio the
reporter was arrested after officer said
he was being too loud while the Ohio
governor spoke about a train development
in the state all right the first thing
I'll say is you know maybe I don't know
don't show up and be a dick while
someone's trying to warn the public
about something that's going on not to
necessarily trust these people
they say the reporter Evan Lambert had
been waiting for the news conference in
East Palestine I guess people are saying
it's called Palestine to start but it
was delayed until 5 PM the later time
coincided with when he was scheduled to
do a live shot for the show so that's it
they arrested him because he was doing a
live shot and he was being noisy I mean
that's kind of ridiculous right
I think that's ridiculous although the
fact that it's the New York Times
reporting on it and I feel like they
would never cover most journalists
getting kicked out of things makes me
wonder what else is going on I mean he
wrapped his live shot as soon as he
realized the governor was speaking they
arrested him anyway have you seen the
video of it is it no is it crazy it's
it's kind of crazy he's definitely like
it I didn't see the part like I said I
saw it when he was getting confronted by
cops right and they're telling him he
has to go there's like an um a National
Guard guy in uniform who kind of shoves
him but they're already kind of having a
heated exchange and then they force him
out onto the ground he like drops the
floor he doesn't want to move uh it's
obviously something's going on but at
the in the video oh is this right here
who instigates it this is it before that
he's in sort so right now he's like in a
vestibule before because they're
obviously well you know I mean you know
journalists they're uh they're bad
people you know what I mean you gotta
you gotta arrest them because they're
you know they're trying to
trying to lie to the American people
right I mean I I agree but not really
I'm not kinda most of them are bad
people I don't know I think at this
point
it's true I just you know like
you you don't make money telling people
what's going on anymore like yo we all
saw it happen on Twitter so so what ends
up happening is these news organizations
are just like how can we maximize
traffic for the sake of traffic and
getting clicks
and then they just you know
I mean look I'm not saying this guy did
but I wouldn't be surprised if there
were reporters who tried to get arrested
so they can then oh look at me oh geez
oh they're trying to shut down the Press
yeah I I imagine that that does happen
but I think that probably happens more
with people that are like on the ground
reporters trying to like stir up
problems at like protests and stuff like
that you know what I mean well there's a
lot of activists who pretend to be
journalists exactly they go around
screaming I'm a journalist and throw a
brick or something yeah I'm exaggerating
thinking of activists where are all the
climate change and ecosystems crazy
people
they're breathing their pure air
somewhere else yeah they're in they're
in Georgia complaining about police
wanting to build a police building oh
God yeah that's climate change has to do
with the police in Georgia
it's because it's because the police
want to tear down these trees to build a
a police training facility so these
antifa people came from out of state uh
crossing state lines with guns yeah I
mean that but they're actually very
seriously they're probably being paid to
do that firstly no I don't know about I
I can't leave their day job I guess yeah
I really don't think they're getting
paid Starbucks jobs not covering their
ammunition you'd build bills but you
don't need to pay cult members yeah
members do it for free you get you pay
all you gotta give you supplies yeah you
pay you pay for their their
transportation or whatever make sure
they can get to a place and then you
just make sure that the D.A is uh
sufficiently left leaning so that way
they don't prosecute people that are
does that mean on the books
on the books I mean I don't know on the
books but I'm you know the thing is like
if you if you've got left-leaning groups
that are giving a bunch of money to yeah
of course uh District Attorneys uh races
and stuff like that and you know they
get elected isn't it crazy that news
organizations endorse politicians I mean
I think it's terrible well I mean it
makes sense why why does it make sense
because this is the it's the I mean I
look at how the news has changed over
the last 20 years and it's like the the
the mainstream media's viewership is
deteriorated with the explosion of the
internet and so they can't really afford
to keep up with you with with platforms
like YouTube and all these other things
and so click bait was created Because
the Internet is they had to figure out a
way how to get people with their
short-term memory immediately immediate
response immediate response and so that
the way that advertising done the way
that headlines are written the way that
everything is has changed and so the
whole concept behind you know
journalistic Integrity is not rewarded
in this new era of media right where
it's like we're used to when I was a kid
you know you watch Walter Cronk Cronkite
and Barbara Walters and they they don't
tell you what to think they just tell
the story you know that's what the news
used to do and then you figure it out
for yourself and things are always a
little bit leaning to one degree or
another but the media in the mainstream
media leaning thing was and was not
tolerated by the public I I disagree I
think the issue was they were the
principal sources of information and so
they always tried to play middle of the
road to the best of their abilities out
of fear that they would spark a
controversy so it's not it's it's it's
sort of true what you're saying I should
say I agree mostly but the idea is like
The Newsroom always was motivated by
maximizing viewership and they were like
well we'll lose 10 of our audience if we
do that then when the internet arose and
everyone got to choose their tribal
hangout they said if we don't choose a
tribe then we get no one and then yeah
that makes people catered or made made
the outlets cater to the audience more
you think yeah yeah well do you think
that now after all this that people are
ready for Middle of the Road Media I'd
say maybe but um I don't I don't know if
middle of the road is the right way to
view it I think what's happening is
you know look I think
you get a staunchly conservative show it
will get substantially more views than a
show like this you give a staunchly
leftist show it'll get substantially
more views than this regardless of
whether it's correct researched or
otherwise so you know you take a look at
the biggest political cultural streamer
in in the world and it's
ill researched or not researched at all
but it's Tribal so say what needs to be
said say what the audience wants to hear
you'll get way more traffic say what the
audience doesn't want to hear they get
mad at you they unsubscribe they stop
giving you money and then your company
falls apart
so you gotta you gotta make sure you're
siding with the audience as it goes I
don't know though maybe it's unfair to
say because I guess this show is the is
the highest average live audience on
YouTube for the time slot you know there
are other streams that get more viewers
but we consistently are the top live
show at this time so maybe that's
there's something to be said about that
I will say though you take a look at our
total views like a podcast of this show
we'll get 400 to 500 can YouTube we get
like 100 or so on Apple and Spotify
Tucker Carlson gets around that in his
one hour show slot in the key demo but
then he gets another couple million from
the older crowd so my question is when
that older crowd let's just say ages out
what happens to Media you know like we
may be relatively big but we're we're a
fraction of the size of of Tucker right
I think partially that there's going to
be
um as the Baby Boomers you know age out
like you age out of life there will be
there will be you know people that will
be going into the age bracket where
they're paying more attention to news
and paying more attention to uh you know
finances and and things that you worry
about when you're you know 50 60 70
years old I think that that's the kind
of thing that that there's a replacement
um by the younger generation and that
that that demographic is probably going
to they won't be going to your average
or your your mainstream news but they'll
be looking to places like YouTube
as they get more interested in in topics
that that affect them because I think
the young people don't really pay
attention a lot I think it's a it's a
rare thing so and they don't have cable
I mean fewer people have cable news I
mean I don't remember the last time I
paid for cable and had cable at a place
where I live like I I get my news off of
the clips that a lot of media companies
now realizing they need to put out if
they're going to survive I also think to
your point about newsrooms endorsing
people it it's been going on for like a
century but it used to be the editorial
team at the newspaper so a small subset
to people who wrote who were known for
writing their opinions came together and
selected someone to endorse it wasn't
necessarily although of course it's hard
to separate it wasn't necessarily the
entire staff right it wasn't like
everyone there got to say oh let's think
about this who who do we like for
president you know a select group of
people got to that and it was
representational of generally the
paper's endorsement and I think now we
have an even more blurred perspective
I'm what's news and Reporting and what's
editorial right like what we do here is
news but a lot of it is editorial I'm
giving you my opinion on well this show
is opinion it's opinion exactly but like
you know we give you some news and our
thoughts on it but uh it's not like we
come on the show and we literally just
read facts and then leave no not at all
and I think that's where it becomes
confusing because it sounds like these
authorities you know the New York Times
The Washington Post that theoretically
are presenting facts in straight news
middle of the line are then saying oh
this this is the better choice it makes
it sound like it's coming from an
informed factual position when actually
it's all editorial it's opinion based
yeah I mean the greatest thing is New
York Times has like 10 million
subscribers still I can't believe that
yeah what do they pay like 10 bucks a
month or something still they've been
growing and that's the power of uh
Legacy and name recognition people who
look you can't sell a product no one
knows about everybody knows what the New
York time is New York Times is so they
want they want to read the news they
just buy that and they don't realize
they're being lied to a large portion of
time now the New York Times doesn't a
good job with a lot of basic reporting
but when it comes to politics they're
just pissing on your face but they're
saying right and all of these places are
competing for the same people I think
the same because you made it is saying
um The Washington Post has major layoffs
right now I mean they're competing for
the same uh I want to say subscribers
but I don't remember what it's called
when it's actual print paper uh you know
they're competing for the same
subscription yeah they're competing for
the same people to pay for them that are
paying for the New York Times right and
if they're basically giving you the same
editorial positions on politics and
everything else and they're doing the
same type of reporting or maybe the New
York Times is doing it better why would
people pay for their service right well
that's a problem it just seems like each
side of the aisle has the have their
their messaging is unilateral and it's
just that's why people are like younger
people are moving away from traditional
media it's also too they keep the
they've lost like anyone who can use a
computer at this point I feel like can
just fact check
uh in any article and they're like oh
they're just lying to us and we've seen
they don't open they they'll go to the
New York Times and it'll be like Donald
Trump works for Russia and they'll go
whoa
whoa and then there's there's no ounce
of curiosity like who told them that
they're like an anonymous guy we met
close to the office of Donald Trump
confirms and what they mean by that is a
homeless guy in the alley who's
physically close to his office thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time